in two mosques worshipers are gathered
for Friday prayers this was the
aftermath in one of them minutes after a
gunman had walked in and opened fire
floor people are bleeding to death
seven died here one were in hospital
afterwards
this is thought to be minutes later the
moment police had rammed the Killer's
vehicle and are pulling him out of his
car at gunpoint
dozens were killed in the two attacks
survivors left in a State of Shock
I could only you know the blood is
spitting on me I mean I was splashing on
me and I think oh my God oh my God it's
gonna happen to me now I saw one gun in
the floor
and produce water stopping here there
was a lot of people doing you don't
think something like this could happen
in New Zealand well in Christchurch of
all places with such a small community
we're so kind and loving so I just don't
understand why someone would hurt us
like this and in such a way
just like an animal like why would you
treat us like that the Bangladeshi
cricket team had been due to join Friday
prayers in one of the mosques and miss
the massacre by only a few minutes
I would say that we are very lucky if we
had reached the mosque three to four
minutes before then it would have been a
massive incident but I'm thankful we're
very lucky because we are not at that
place we thought from outside like
watching a video like in the movies we
saw many people coming out bloodied
outside one mosque this woman tried to
save the life of a victim in vain I've
never I never thought of him I'm 66 and
never thought of my life I'd love to see
something like this not in New Zealand
so horrible can we really commend you
for what you did you're really a hero
for taking it
no
just
do it the time
I wish I could have done more
this doesn't happen in New Zealand or it
never has till now escaping terrorist
attacks and mass shootings that have
plagued so many other countries
that said prime minister Jacinda ardern
was what made New Zealand the target for
these appalling Acts
we New Zealand
we were not a Target because we're a
safe harbor for those who hate
we were not chosen for this act of
violence because we condone racism
because we're an enclave for extremism
we were chosen for the very fact that we
are none of these things
because we represent diversity
kindness
compassion
a home for those who share our values
refuge for those who need it
and those values I can assure you
will not and cannot be shaken by this
attack
the government decided to live stream
the attack as he carried it out on
social media Sky News is not showing
that video on social media he called
himself Brenton Tarrant he's been
identified as an Australian National we
stand here
and condemn absolutely
the attack that occurred today
by an extremist
right-wing violent terrorist
that has taken the lives stolen the
lives
in a vicious murderous attack
that is
claimed so many
new zealanders
the mayor of Christ Church has called
for calm on what she described as a
dreadful day
I've never could believe that something
like this would ever happen in the city
of Christchurch but actually I would
never believe that this would ever
happen in New Zealand and it looks as if
something the worst has happened and we
need to pull together and get through
this situation several Firearms have
been recovered to improvise explosive
devices found strapped to a car a number
of people have been arrested none
thought to be on a terror watch list
while the investigation begins New
Zealand must come to terms with the
brutal truth that nowhere today seems
safe from extremist Terror Dominic
wyghorn Sky News